in this video we will discuss a little
bit about the biggest iron from the
anime attack on titan and we will
showcase 10 monsters that are even
bigger
than this gigantic entity just a bit of
trivia
this island is even bigger than godzilla
earth which was around 300 meters or
1000 feet tall
the air in founding titan was 350 meters
tall
and 600 meters long so around 1150 feet
tall
and 2000 feet long so yeah it's pretty
big
and for those who haven't seen this
anime do check it out but before we go
into this video do click the subscribe
button to be a part of the mind cue
family
and now let's get down with this
sickness
in attack on titan the so-called titans
were species of giant man-eating
humanoids that served as a catalyst for
the events of the series
the progenitor titan also known as the
founding titan was the
first of all titans and one of the
original nine titans
its scream had the ability to create and
control other titan as well as alter the
memories and body composition of
immersed subjects
the founding title could transform
subjects emerged to into tyrants and
could even make them as
massive as the colossus style which was
around 60 meters
or 200 feet tall so as said before this
founding titan was
350 meters or 1150 feet tall
and 600 meters or 2000 feet long
but now let's see other monsters bigger
than this one
number 10 gaia from god of war gaia is a
primordial being
the titan's mother and the olympian gods
grandmother slash
great-grandmother she is the series
narrator god of war 2's deuteronos
and god of war 3's secondary antagonists
gaia was once a caring and loving titan
helping anyone no matter what the cause
however after the great war when all the
titans were punished for the crimes of
one
gaia's heart became filled with hatred
for zeus and the olympians
this titan was around 400 to 500 meters
tall a 1
300 to 1 600 feet tall around 100 meters
taller than founding diamond
number 9 cronus from wrath of the titans
in the 2012 film wrath of the titans
cronus is the main adversary
he is the titans leader and a father of
the gods krona's physical form
is made out of molten rock and lava and
cronus body
mouth and eyes are surrounded by love
alliance implying that the inside of his
body is entirely made of magma
he is capable of projecting massive
waves from lava from his arms
and he's also seen spawning hordes of
makai which are small soldiers of his
from his very own flesh and his size is
around 500 meters tall
or 1640 feet tall this titan is 150
meters taller than the founding titan
number eight exaggerate this one from
star wars is called an exogarth
commonly known as a space slug and are
silicon-based sentient species who live
in asteroids holes
and lay dormant within one until food
comes by
in the hot asteroid belt at least one
such entities lived there
called scio and space locks reach full
maturity at 10 meters but
reproduce by splitting into two smaller
separate bodies if a space lock was
incapable of this process
its growth continues uninterrupted
potentially reaching
up to lengths of 900 meters or 3000 feet
long
so around 300 meters or 1000 feet longer
than the founding dayton
number 7 certa this next entry is from
the mcu
and certain was a fire demon that ruled
muspelheim and was mentioned in
ragnarok's prophecy as the one
who would bring asgard's downfall odin
fought certa
thousands of years ago in order to
prevent this prophecy returning the
source of his strength the eternal flame
to asgard
and confining certain to maspelheim
where he resided for nearly 5000 years
there
in thor ragnarok when his crown was
combined with the eternal flame he was
resurrected and grew to around
500 to 1 000 meters tall before
destroying asgard
number six the reapers coming from the
game mass effect the reapers are a
highly advanced
machine race of synthetic organic
starships the reapers reside in dark
space
the vast mostly stylish space between
galaxies
they hibernate their dormant for 50 000
years at a time
before returning to the galaxy to prey
on unsuspecting species
these gigantic machines are ancient and
their true name is unknown
reapers was a name bestowed by the
protheans a previous galactic power 50
000 years before us and these mostly
living spaceships
are between one to two kilometers in
length
number five parallax parallax is a
demonic parasitic entity dating back to
the dawn of time
this parasite was a sentient embodiment
of fear traveling from world to world
and causing entire civilizations to
destroy themselves out of paranoia in
the movie green lantern
parallax was released from its prison
made by a green lantern called abensur
and started to terrorize the galaxy
feeding off of the fear of living beings
and growing as it does
and by the time it reaches earth it was
two to three kilometers in size
and this will make it three to five
times bigger than a founding titan just
by length
number four yerman gander this is
another monster from the god of war
series of games
and this one is from norse mythology
instead of the greek ones of the first
three games yorman gander also known as
the world serpent is a mythical
jotun serpent destined to fight thor
come ragnarok
he becomes an ally of craters and atrius
after the pair awakened him from deep
slumber within the lake of nine
it befriends the protagonist's craters
and his son and during the game
we can see his length being anywhere
between four to five kilometers long
pretty huge number three the summer
verminath
this one is another monster from star
wars and the space monsters
summer vermont were gigantic
space-faring species of legend that
dwelled within the academy's maelstrom
around the planet castle with numerous
eyes and electrified tentacles that they
used to ensnare prey
summer vermont were often misunderstood
creatures at 7
432 meters long they spot multiple eyes
and numerous large tentacles a summer
vermont's tentacle
were armed with suckers and electrified
stingers which they used to trap prey
and even catch spaceships like the
millennium falcon in the movie
solo a star wars story number two the
cloverfield monster
first seen in the first glove field
movie the monster came from the atlantic
ocean where it was awakened by
some submarines from the japanese sent
down from the chuwai station to
investigate anomalies
the monster rampages through manhattan
destroying the city
in its path but this was stated to be
just a baby and the monstrous adult was
seen briefly in the third
installment of the movie series in
cloverfield paradox scene in the end of
the movie
towering above the clouds with various
estimates putting the creature's size
at around five to eight kilometers tall
and number one can you guess it yeah
it's void ghidorah
the number one spot is of course the
three-headed rival of godzilla earth
ghidorah in this movie is very different
from his previous forms
but he also retains the famous look of a
three-headed dragon nonetheless with two
wings two tails and two legs although we
couldn't see the
entire body just the neck he does not
stand iraq at all and his position
horizontally rather than vertically
despite the fact that he has feet but he
just comes up from black holes
what the hell the bodies have golden
fiery appearance and the head have long
narrowed tooth like appendages from the
mouth and many eyes
which we can't even count which is a
first for the kaiju
but nonetheless this version is the
biggest easily over 15 to 20 kilometers
long
and the first on this list and with that
we come to the end of the video of the
10 monsters even bigger than the erin
founding titan from the series attack on
titan
although the first four entries were
rivals in size once the sixth entry came
the founding tyrant became a smudge in
comparison anyway tell us what you think
and showcase your master knowledge in
the comments section with other monsters
bigger than the titan because we know
there are more
so click that like button for support
that subscribe button too
and of course the bell button for
regular updates on new monster videos
right here on minecube till the next one
take care fam